turning now to a massive potential new
spending push from the biden
administration
we're talking about reports of up to
three trillion dollars as with a t
to be pumped into the u.s economy that's
if the proposals backers can get their
way on that
nancy cordes is at the white house with
more on this story nancy good morning to
you sure seems like a tall order with
everything that's going on there these
days
gail it is a very ambitious plan it has
to do with
infrastructure the next big item on the
biden agenda we're told that within the
next couple of days
president biden's economic advisors are
going to be briefing him
on a proposal that they say will create
jobs and it involves spending about a
trillion dollars reportedly
on improvements to roads bridges even
the cellular networks that's the
physical
infrastructure piece then more money
would go to investments like
free community college universal pre-k
and
paid family leave they call that human
infrastructure so
this is a very aggressive plan and the
challenge for democrats here is that the
senate
is so closely split that it's just as
hard to push this through
without bipartisan support as it is to
pass other big
priorities for democrats like
immigration reform
gun safety and voting rights and in this
case
if democrats try to pay for these
infrastructure initiatives with
higher taxes on wealthy americans or
corporations
then it's going to be very difficult to
pick up any republican support
tony all right nancy thank you very much
too big